how much do people have to kind of date
around to find somebody though because
it does take a bit of exploration to
find somebody you're compatible with
so what's a reasonable amount of
exploration and like by what age should
people have
figured it out because i mean there's
always the grass looks greener
so at some point maybe you should just
settle down but what are your thoughts
on that
well life isn't very long and so you
don't get
to evaluate that many relationships you
probably only have a five to ten year
period to do that something like
that and then the reason you only have
that amount of time is because it gets
more and more difficult as you get older
rather than easier
partly because people your age are
increasingly in relationships
so i would say get at it don't don't
overestimate the degree to which
you have to find someone versus create
the relationship
you know there's many cultures and i'm
not suggesting that this is
necessarily a desirable alternative
there are many cultures that arrange
marriages
and those arranged marriages frequently
work it's not obvious that they work
less frequently than
relationships or marriages that are
predicated on romantic attraction
which has its own pitfalls no matter who
you find they're going to be full of
flaws like you are and so a lot of it is
something you create
i think you want to find someone you can
trust and someone that you're attracted
to
and perhaps someone who shares the same
ambitions as you do or at least has
ambitions that are compatible with yours
and then
well then pretty much all of it after
that is what you create
rather than what you find